(cheerful piano music)
- [Narrator] This is the
Panamanian golden frog.
A frog so rare it may no
longer exist in the wild.
Merely inches in size, this
frog's ornate skin is stunning.
But also quite poisonous.
The frog is covered in deadly toxins
to protect itself from predators.
In the wild, it feasts on insects
that it finds near streams
in the mountainous rain forests of Panama.
But a combination of
deforestation, poaching,
and a devastating fungal
disease laid waste
to their population.
But there is still hope
for this special amphibian,
breeding in captivity has been successful.
And continued efforts
are being made to protect
and preserve their habitat.
This is the Panamanian golden frog.
(cheerful piano music)